[Musique]
à 2000 mètres d'altitude une vallée
désertique qui ressemble à une autre
planète
rien ne pousse il n'y a pas d'eau pas
d'animaux pas d'arbres que des cailloux
à perte de vue
et pourtant des hommes et des femmes
vivent ici
tous sont là pour la même chose lors
cachés dans les veines des montagnes
autrefois il travaillait clandestinement
puis ils se sont organisés pour mieux
vivre ensemble ils ont bâti une cité ils
l'ont appelé quattro aulas en mémoire du
temps où ils devaient marcher quatre
heures pour se rendre ici
[Musique]
des pauvres des bidonvilles de lima des
chercheurs d'or fuyant la jungle
amazonienne t paysans venus des
montagnes de l'altiplano où la terre
permet tout juste de vivre tous les
laissés pour compte du pérou se retrouve
à cuatro horas cette ville et leur
dernière chance elle a été fondée en
2003 par 300 mineurs clandestins
à l'époque une grande compagnie minière
lorgner sur les richesses de la région
les pionniers sont allés en justice pour
obtenir le droit d'exploiter la mine en
coopérative aujourd'hui 2500 personnes
vivent dans cette communauté autogéré où
l'or ne fait pas tourner les têtes
comme dans beaucoup d'autres villes du
monde ici il n'ya pas de crime
la prostitution est interdite l'alcool
aussi
[Musique]
à cuatro horas nous avons rencontré la
famille a pas ça ou hilbert sa femme
olga son frère julio cesar et son épouse
jovana ensemble chaque matin ils montent
chercher dans la terre les ressources
pour améliorer leur vie
[Musique]
je m'appelle gilbert a pas ça a choqué
tous main j'ai 31 ans et ça fait cinq
ans que je travaille dans la mine will
berre et fils de boulanger dans les
montagnes de cusco il causait des habits
pour les touristes de passage et ne
gagnez pas grand chose un jour il y a
cinq ans il a entendu parler de quattro
l'as par le bouche à oreille je suis
arrivé avec 60 sol est dans la poche
alors le premier jour j'ai demandé la
femme qui tient l'épicerie de me faire
crédit à un moment on a mangé que du
pain avec des sodas parce que j'avais
pas les moyens pour acheter autre chose
à la mine wilb regagne 160 euros par
mois un peu plus que le salaire moyen au
pérou c'est pourquoi julio cesar a
rejoint son grand frère il y a trois ans
il espérait améliorer le quotidien de sa
famille je suis d'abord arriver ma femme
m'a rejoint plus tard je voulais
m'assurer que je pouvais vivre à cuatro
horas quel type de travail c'était et
six en valait la peine ou pas
nous sommes venus sans rien on n'avait
même pas d'endroit où dormir
on habitait dans une petite cabane
abandonnée c'est petit à petit on a
acheté des affaires on a acheté un lit
et on s'est installé toute la famille
habitent dans des cahutes bâti de paille
le matin lorsqu'il se prépare pour aller
à la mine
julio cesar repense parfois ses
montagnes ses coanimateurs c'est une
région agricole
on a des photos qu'on aime regarder
comme des souvenirs depuis qu'on est
plus chez nous là bas les montagnes sont
plus belles qu'ici où il n'y a que des
pierres parfois elle me manque
énormément
[Musique]
roy nadeau
chaque matin à 6h30
julio cesar gilbert et les autres
mineurs monte à la mine en camion
mais avant de s'enfoncer dans les veines
rocheuses ces hommes observent un rituel
remercier la pachamama la déesse de la
terre wilber n'aurait pas pu trouver de
travail dans une grande mine exploitée
de manière industrielle car il n'a pas
d'expérience mais dans cette petite mine
pour lui a donné sa chance
je travaille comme perforateur enfin je
viens de commencer à ce poste je suis
pas encore totalement sûr de m dans
cette mine on est embauché comme simple
ouvrier
on ne te demande pas de compétences aux
particuliers on est formé sur le tas
le quotidien des hommes est rude
la coopérative n'a pas les moyens
d'acheter des machines
julio cesar étayent les parois avec des
cales en bois parfois au péril de sa vie
les galeries avant d'être renforcée
peuvent à tout moment s'écrouler
mon travail est le plus risqué car
j'entre dans la veine juste après
l'explosion et avant les camarades les
perforateurs pour vérifier l'endroit
voir si c'est dangereux ou non et si
c'est dangereux car les un pilier pour
que mes collègues puissent forêt en
toute sécurité
il ya parfois des blocs de pierre qui se
fissure il faut faire attention à tout
car on ne sait jamais ce qui peut nous
tomber dessus
j'ai déjà eu des accidents et j'ai
souvent la peur au ventre
[Musique]
je laisse faire le destin
il se peut qu'un jour je ne m'en sortais
pas fan ma vie est entre les mains de
dieu
pendant que les hommes exploitent la
mine les femmes sont sur le terril la
coopérative autorise celle qui le
veulent à récupérer les résidus de
minerais olga jovana et leur belle soeur
jessica ils vont régulièrement à l'aube
nous sommes plusieurs à l'est dans la
montagne
comme il ya la concurrence on met
parfois des pierres à la va vite dans
les sacs et au village ont fait une
sélection plus stricte
ensuite je jette ce qui n'a pas de
valeur je me sens très fier de porter
les pierres il y à des femmes qui sont
faites pour ce genre de travail et
d'autres qui ne sont pas on se sent
forte après ça je n'aurais je pas mon
mari à m'aider car il est fatigué à
cause de son propre travail
mais je crois qu'il a impressionné
parfois il me demande comment je fais
pour porter des sacs aussi lourd
de retour chez elle olga casse chaque
caillou en espérant qu'ils renferment de
l'or l'argent qu'elles gagnent servir à
tous les petits extras de la famille à
épargner aussi il faut être endurcies
pour travailler à la mine pour supporter
l'austérité des montagnes alentour
pourtant où il versait qu'il a fait le
bon choix en tentant sa chance à quoi tu
leur laisses et en y faisant venir sa
famille tout le monde vit correctement
ça me rend heureux d'être ici en famille
la coopératif et tout pour inciter les
mineurs à venir avec femme et enfants
pour créer à quoi tu leur as une
bourgade durable et pas simplement un
campement de travailleurs à la dure
l'entreprise garantit les services
publics de base sans aucune aide de
l'état
l'eau et l'électricité sont fournis
gratuitement comme les téléphone
portable ne capte pas il y a une cible
pour communiquer avec l'extérieur
l'entreprise paie même l'école et les
professeurs c'est ce qui a convaincu
olga les pousses de gilbert de
s'installer ici je ne serais pas resté
si longtemps ce qu'il n'y avait pas eu
d'école je veux une autre vie pour mon
fils je n'ai pas envie qu'ils vivent
dans la pauvreté
quattro ross est un village calme
vous avez vu qu'il ya un poste de
contrôle avant de rentrer au village
tout le monde ne peut pas rentrer ici et
les gens n'ont pas le droit de boire un
règlement strict grâce auquel il y a peu
de violence dans le village les femmes
vivent en sécurité pendant que les
hommes sont à la mine leur épouse
s'occupe des enfants et des maisons
tiennent les épiceries et les boutiques
ce sont elles qui ont préparé la fête de
ce soir celle de la salle ita sainte
patronne des pauvres au pérou si les
femmes n'étaient pas là je crois qu'il
n'y aurait pas de joie dans le village
je crois que les hommes seraient tristes
qui habitent seules parts alors que ceux
qui habitent avec leurs femmes restent
ici et vivre plus heureux
[Musique]
pourtant le rêve des mineurs reste
précaire
nous sommes au dispensaire payé par la
mine lorsqu'un accident vient nous le
rappeler
un blessés arrivent touché par une chute
de pierres lanta y profondes restent
bénignes
il n'y a encore jamais eu de décès à
quoi tu leur as mais le médecin redoute
maintenant d'autres accidents comme la
production est insuffisante
les cadences sont augmentées afin de
rembourser les investissements nous dit
il la coopérative n'est pas rentable
dans sa maison où il bear head sa femme
a cassé les pierres ramené du terril lui
aussi sans que quelque chose est en
train de changer
peu à peu une autre réalité économique
se dessine parfois on nous paye pas la
date exacte
toutefois ça prend du temps comme cette
entreprise est pas stable y a pas que de
la joie on s'inquiète aussi je dois
veiller sur mon frère où mon beau-frère
savoir comment ils vont dans la mine
depuis quelques mois les conditions de
travail se sont dégradées il y a moins
d'or dans la mine les femmes aussi
trouvera moins de minerai sur le terril
après cinq années passées ici la famille
à ma façon
donc à partir je crois que c'est ma
dernière année ici je ne sais pas encore
là cela dépend de ce qu'on obtient je
pars parce que le travail ne paye pas
assez ce n'est plus comme avant
une ville de passage
telle pourrait être la définition de
cuatro horas elle donne la possibilité
aux plus modestes de se reconstruire en
famille d'épargné pour poursuivre leur
chemin ensuite arrivé sans terre et sans
argent
olga maintenant un rêve bien à elle mon
projet c'est d'abord une petite maison à
arequipa que je suis en train de
construire et je voudrais ouvrir le
commerce on sera plus tranquille là bas
il n'y aura pas de lourdes charges
apporte un bon mari pourra trouver un
travail en plein air un travail qui
n'exploite pas nos corps
comme les à pass à 100 millions de
personnes dans le monde travaillent dans
des petites mines d'or dans l'espoir
d'une vie meilleure mais dans beaucoup
de cités minières la cupidité
l'emportent sur le collectif cuatro
horas elle prouve qu'il est possible de
bâtir une ville solidaire autour de l'or
ce pari fou encore fragile pourra-t-il
un jour servir de modèle